foreign
[Music]
culture and opinions and I think it
works with your culture it's this is the
first time that I come to a World Cup
you know with alcohol is banner and I
think it's a good you know a good thing
because first of all
there's no problems by not drinking a
lot of alcohol I think it does hinder
certain fan bases obviously the English
are renowned for being you know pretty
passionately drunk the Aussies
especially last night you could tell
they're missing their VBS so obviously
it hinders for certain Nations but
overall the experience is experiencing a
great game of football so at the end of
the day alcohol or not you should be
here to enjoy the soccer disappointed
because
um
before we came the arrangements were
there it was going to be allowed at the
stadiums but um listen you've got to go
with what the rules are in different
countries so we're happy just to abide
and respect people's cultures and we
don't really need the alcohol to enjoy
ourselves but it's a nice social thing
to have
[Music]
it doesn't affect anything here in the
Qatar World Cup and even The Vibes it's
still people they are cheering for any
matches for any country
[Music]
oh
[Applause]